the goal in this video is to essentially
prove a pretty simple result and that's
that the ratio between the volumes let
me write this down
that the ratio between the volume at
state B and the volume at state a so the
ratio of that volume to that volume is
equal to in our Carnot cycle is equal to
the ratio between the volume of state C
so this volume and that volume so volume
it's e to the volume at D so this is
what I'm about to embark to prove a
fairly simple result that maybe is even
if you look at this it's that looks
about right so if you're happy just
knowing that you don't have to watch the
rest of the video but if you are curious
how we get there I encourage you to
watch it although it gets a little bit
mathy but I think the fun part about it
even you know one satisfy you that this
is true but the other thing is we'll be
able to study adiabatic processes a
little bit more so just kind of
launching off of that the whole proof
revolves around this step right here and
this step right here when we go from D
to a so by definition an adiabatic
process is one where there's no transfer
of heat so our heat transfer in an
adiabatic process is zero so if we go
back to our original definition so let
me show you that here right here at this
step in this step we have no transfer of
heat so if we go back to there adiabatic
we're completely isolated from the rest
of the world so there's nothing to
transfer heat to or from so if we go to
our our definition almost or our first
law of thermodynamics we know that the
change in internal energy change in
internal energy is equal to the heat
applied to the system minus the work
done by the system and the work done by
the system is equal to the pressure of
the system times some change in volume
at least you know maybe it's a very
small change in volume while the
pressure is constant but if we're doing
a a quasi-static process we can write
this pressure can you can view it as
kind of constant for that little very
small change in volume so that's what we
have there now if it's adiabatic we know
that this is zero we know that this
right there is zero and if that's zero
we can add P Delta V to both sides of
this equation and we will get then this
is only true if we're adiabatic the
Delta U our change in internal energy
plus our pressure times our change in
volume is equal to zero let's see if we
can do this somehow we can do something
with this equation to get to that result
that I'm trying to get to so a few
videos ago I prove to you that you the
internal energy at any point in time let
me write it here the internal energy at
any point of time is equal to let me is
equal to three-halves times n times R
times T which is also equal to
three-halves times P V now if I have a
change in internal energy what can
change on this side something must have
changed
well three-halves can't change n can't
change we're not going to change the
number of molecules we have the
universal gas constant can't change so
the temperature must change so there you
have it you have Delta you could be
rewritten as Delta let me do it in a
different color Delta you could be
written as 3 halves n times R times our
change in temperature and that's why I
keep saying in this especially when
we're dealing with the situation where
all of the internal energy is
essentially kinetic energy that if you
don't have a change in temperature
you're not going to have a change in
internal energy likewise if you don't
have a change in internal energy you're
not going to have a change in
temperature so let me put this aside
right here I'm going to substitute it
back there but let's see if we can if we
can do something with this with this P
here well we'll just resort to our our
ideal gas equation because we're dealing
with an ideal gas we might as well PV is
equal to NRT this is should be should be
emblazoned in your mind at this point so
if we want to solve for P we get P is
equal to n R T over V fair enough so
let's put both of these things aside and
substitute them into this formula so
Delta U is equal to this
so that means that three-halves n r
delta T plus P so plus P P is this thing
plus n R T over V times Delta V times
Delta V that's the Delta V is equal to 0
interesting so what can we do for the
year and I'll kind of tell you where I'm
going with this so this tells me if I
over my change in internal energy over a
very small delta T this tells me my work
done by the system over a very small
Delta V and we're saying that we you
know over at each little small
increments they're going to add up to
zero what I want to do is Inc so this is
let me just go back to the original
graph so this is over a very small Delta
V right there let me do it in a more
vibrant color a very small change as we
go from there to let's say there we're
going to have some change in our volume
and you don't see the top the
temperature here so don't try to even
imagine when we do the integral that we
should think of it in some times of area
but we're going to integrate over the
change in temperature as well the
temperature changes a little bit from
there to there so what I want to do this
is over very this is right here over a
small change I want to integrate
eventually over all of the changes that
occur during our adiabatic process so
let's see if we can simplify this before
I break out the calculus so if we divide
both sides by NRT what do we get so
let's divided by n RT let's divide it by
n RT and we have to do to both sides of
this equation and RT well on this term
the ends cancels out the R cancels out
over here this NRT cancels out with this
NRT and what are we left with
we're left with three-halves we have
this 1 over T left times 1 over T delta
T plus plus 1 over V Delta V is equal to
zero divided by anything is just is
equal to zero is equal to zero now we're
going to integrate over a bunch of
really small Delta T's and
and end and Delta V so let me just
change those to our calculus terminology
we're going to set do an infinite sum
over an infinitesimally small changes in
delta T and Delta V so I'll rewrite this
as 3 halves 1 over T DT plus 1 over V DV
is equal to 0 remember this just means a
very very small change in in volume this
is a very very very small change
infinitesimally small change in
temperature and now I want to do the
total change in temperature and the
total I want to integrate over the total
change in temperature and the total
change in volume so let's do that so I
want to go from always temperature
temperature start to temperature finish
the temperature finish and this will be
going from our volume start volume start
to volume finish fair enough let's do
these integrals we've just this tends to
show up a lot in thermodynamics these
these anti derivatives the
antiderivative over 1 over T is natural
log of T so this is equal to
three-halves times the natural log of T
we're going to evaluate it at the final
temperature and then the starting
temperature plus plus the natural log
the antiderivative of 1 over V is just
the natural log of V plus the natural
log of V evaluated from our Farmar well
from our final velocity we're going to
subtract out the starting velocity this
is just the calculus here and this is
going to be equal to 0 right now I mean
we could integrate both sides of this
equal if every infinitesimal change is
equal to the sum is equal to 0 the sum
of all of the infinitesimal changes are
also going to be equal to 0 so this is
still equal to 0 see what we can do here
so that we could rewrite this green part
as so it's three-halves times the
natural log of TF minus the natural log
of TS which is just using our log
properties
natural log of TF over the natural log
of TS right when you evaluate you get
natural log of TF minus the natural log
of TS that's the same thing as this plus
plus for the same reason the natural log
of VF over the natural log of V s when
you evaluate this as the natural log of
VF minus the natural log of V S which
can be simplified this to this from just
from our logarithmic properties so that
equals zero and now we can this
coefficient out front we can use our
logarithmic properties instead of
putting a three half natural log of this
we can rewrite this as the natural log
of TF over TS to the three halves now we
can keep doing our logarithm properties
you take the log of something plus the
log of something that's equal to the log
of their product so this is equal to
I'll switch colors this is equal to the
natural log the natural log of TF over
TS to the three half power times the
natural log of VF over V s and this is a
fatiguing proof all right and all of
that is going to be equal to zero now
what can we say well we're saying that e
to the zero power write the natural log
is log base E e to the zero power is
equal to this thing so this thing must
be 1 e to the zero power is one so we
can say we're almost there we can say
that TF TFR final temperature over our
starting temperature to the three half
power times our final volume over our
starting volume is equal to 1 now let's
take this result that we we worked
reasonably hard to produce let's take
this result remember all of this we just
said we're dealing with an adiabatic
process and we started from the
principle of just what the definition of
internal energy is and then we
substitute it with kind of our PV equals
NRT formulas although this was kind of
PV you know the
is the internal energy at any point is
equal to three halves times PV and then
we got and then we integrated over all
of the changes and we said look this is
adiabatic so the total change has to the
sum of all of our all of our change in
internal energy and work done by the
system has to be zero then we use the
property of log to get to this result
now let's do these for both of these
adiabatic processes over here so the
first one we could do is this one where
we go from volume B at t1 to volume C at
T to watch the Carnot video Carnot cycle
video if you forgot that this was VB all
of these things up here were at
temperature one all of the things down
here we're at temperature two so we're
at temperature one up here and
temperature two down here at volume C so
let's look at that so on that right part
that write process our final temperature
was temperature two so let me write it
down temperature - our initial
temperature was temperature one where we
started off at point B to the
three-halves times what was our final
volume our final volume was our volume
at C divided by the volume at B and
that's going to be equal to one neat
that was what that's the result we got
from this adiabatic process we got that
formula saying that this is adiabatic we
did a bunch of math and then we just
substitute for our initial and final
volumes and temperatures let's do it the
same way but let's go from D to a so
when you go from D to a when you go from
D to a what's your final temperature let
me don't want to get you dizzy going up
and what your final temperature we're
going from D to a so our final
temperature is t1 and our final volume
is the volume at a go back down so our
final temperature is t1 our initial
temperature is t2 we're going from D to
a to the three halves power is x times
let me write our formula there are final
our final volume is a volume at a that's
where we moved to from and we moved from
our volume at D and this is going to be
equal to one
okay we're almost there if you're
getting if your eyes are beginning to
glaze over but this is interesting and
if anything it's a little bit of fun
mathematics to to wake you up in the
morning so let's see if we can almost
relate these two things we could set
them equal to each other but it's not
quite satisfying yet let's take the
reciprocal of both sides of let's take
the reciprocal of both sides of this
equation right here so obviously if we
take the reciprocal of this any you know
this is we could just say this is t2
over t1 to the minus three halves power
which is the same thing as which is the
same thing as t1 over t2 to the three
halves power right that's just the
reciprocal and we're taking it at both
sides to the negative one power so we're
going to take this to the negative one
power
VB over VC and when you take the
reciprocal of one that just equals one
that's still equals one and which is
this also equals so we can say that
equals this thing over here so that is
equal to t1 over t2 to the three-halves
power times VA over VD now these things
are equal to each other we can get rid
of the one these two actually let me
just erase let me erase some of this I
want to make it say not equal to they're
equal to each other they both equal one
so they both equal each other these both
equal each other well this thing and
this thing are the same thing t1 over t2
to the three-halves T 1 over T to the
three-halves so let's just divide both
sides by that those cancel out and what
are we left with I think you can see the
finish line the finish line is near we
have VB over VC is equal to VA over VD
now that's not quite the result we
wanted but it takes a little bit of
simple rhythmic arithmetic to get there
let's just cross multiply and you get VB
times VD is equal to VC times VA now if
we multiply if we divide both sides by
by let's divide both sides by VB VC
so if we divide both sides by VB VC
actually let's do it the other way let's
divide both sides by VD VA VD V a VD V a
what do we get these cancel out and
these cancel out and we are left with VB
over VA is equal to VC over VD all that
work for a nice and simple result but
that's better than doing a lot of work
for a hairy and monstrous result so
that's what we set out to prove that VB
over VA is equal to VC over VD and we
got it all from the notion that we're
dealing with adiabatic process that our
change in heat is zero and we just went
to our formula or our definition of our
change in internal energy the first law
of thermodynamics that if we have any
change in internal energy it must be
equal to the amount of work done by the
system or at least a negative done of
the work done by the system when you add
them up you get to zero then we use that
result from a few videos ago where we
said three the internal energy at any
point is three halves times NRT so the
change in internal energy is that times
delta T because that's the only thing
that can change we use PV equal NRT and
then we just integrated along all of the
little changes in temperature and volume
as we moved along this line as we moved
along the line we took the integral we
said that had to be equal to zero and we
ended up with this formula over here and
then we just applied it to our two
adiabatic processes when we went from B
to C and we went from D to a and we got
these results and we got to our finish
line see you in the next video